[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren live aus
der Flora zu Köln der große
nrw-staatspreis geht an Doktor Angela
Merkel aber das spielt heute überhaupt
keine Rolle denn viel wichtiger hier
wird gleich Hendrik wüst zum
cdu-kanzlerkandidaten gekürt
[Musik]
Herr Laschet hallo wie geht's ihnen
Hendrik wüst wird heute zum
Kanzlerkandidaten der CDU gekürt und wir
möchten dass Sie die Nachricht Markus
Söder überbringen Angela Merkel kriegt
heute den Staatspreis des Landes
passiert auch und dieses Signal senden
wir auch nach Bayern
Herr Steinbrück für die jüngeren
Zuschauer sie sind ja quasi der Armin
Laschet der SPD haben sie einen Tipp für
Hendrik wüst kanzlerwahlkampf nicht
komische Frage von ihnen ausgegeben da
haben sie aber lange dran dass sich der
Armin Laschet der SPD bin das möchte sie
denn gerne hören dass sie einen Tipp an
für den kanzlerwahlkampf von Hendrik
wüst
das ist die nächste ganz filigrane Frage
die sich ausgedacht haben da bin ich ja
bekannt aber darüber müssen sie erstmal
mit Herrn Merz reden einverstanden heute
ist ja der Zeitpunkt wo Angela Merkel
Hendrik wüst quasi das Erbe überträgt es
könnte danach aussehen man weiß es nicht
ich bin sehr gespannt alle Anzeichen
deuten darauf hin zum Beispiel das
Friedrich Merz nicht hier ist ja das
liegt vielleicht daran dass er Frau
Merkel ja beim ersten Orden schon nicht
gratuliert hat inzwischen ist auch
Hendrik wüst eingetroffen und meine
seriösen Kollegen stellen seinen
Parteifreunden schon mal kritische
Fragen die Antwort ist ganz einfach es
gab Würstchen und Kartoffelsalat sehr
bodenständig und Angela Merkel Gott das
Glas Bier dann auch noch selbst sein
warum wäre Friedrich Merz der absolut
falsche Kanzlerkandidat Friedrich Merz
ist ein super Parteivorsitzender super
Fraktionsvorsitzender und wenn ich mir
Olaf Scholz anschaue dann würde ich mir
wünschen dass sie sich März
Bundeskanzler werden sagte
Generalsekretär der Armin Laschet zur
Niederlage gegenüber stolz gebracht hat
jetzt haben wir den Finger in die Wunde
legen ich glaube ja ich glaube es
überall
gegen Olaf es ist ja das ist bitter
mir die ja ist es bitte aber sehr lustig
ja es ist es ist bitter und ich trage
eine große Verantwortung dafür ja es ist
so es ist mehr kühlbar das kann man
Hendrik müssten nur als Tipp mitgeben im
kanzlerwahlkampf Paul ziemiak sollte er
nicht nehmen so das müssen sie dann ihm
sagen
er wird mit anderen dann richtig
entscheiden Sie hier seid Corona vorbei
ist ist ihn wirklich einfach nur noch
langweilig oder
ständig aber ich freue mich Angela
Merkel wiederzusehen und so habe mir
diese knappe Zeit aus dem Rippen
geschnitten alle sind heute hier um zu
gratulieren sollte nicht irgendjemand
Friedrich Merz Trost spenden vielleicht
ist er ja unterwegs und kommt noch guter
Witz
hält jetzt hier seine Rede und ich muss
sagen er ist wirklich der wahre CDU
Kanzler habe er bringt den Saal schon
genauso zum Kochen wie Angela Merkel
jeder spürte ihr echtes Interesse an
Menschen also Sorgen und Nöten
ihren ganz unterschiedlichen Biografien
verlasse ich habe mal was für sie noch
ein Geschenk hier für Sie der heute-show
Staatspreis dafür dass Sie Markus Söder
als Kanzler verhindert haben vielen Dank
danke
[Applaus]
was für ein schöner Tag bleibt
eigentlich nur eine Frage offen nehmen
Sie die Kandidatur an
ja einfach weitergehen während die
heute-show alberne Fragen stellt der
Mann ist wirklich Merkels Erbe und damit
zurück ins Studio
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen
also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos und der
Papst in eine Bar sagt der Barkeeper
abonniert endlich denn verpackten heute
schon Kanal also geht doch